[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in nick wright first things
first co-host fox sports one always
great to talk to nick how are you nick
what's on the front burner of nick
wright
oh well first of all great spot with tom
brady good of you to have two future
hall of famers on in the same show or i
guess i'm a current hall of famer but
it's syracuse hall of fame you know
broadcasting hall of fame i assume one
day i i also i would love to ask your
crew i don't know if i'm allowed to what
their favorite moment of the interview
was because i know what mine was
did you guys catch the not so humble
brag by your fearless leader mr patrick
because it was i mean it was hard not to
catch when you said you know tom
i almost said to you on the podium i
know i did
not i was the one handing you the keys
to the truck i was broadcasting the
super bowl in between olympics and other
things it was great it's good good
moment by you wow and i was proud of you
but nick tom has been up there so often
he might have forgot who was up there
with him like patrick mahomes would
remember who was up there with him
because he's only been up there once
oh yeah no that's fair have you been up
there with him more than once
dan
i i would assume yes just the math would
demand it with how many super bowls
you've emceed i was up there with uh
the eagles when they won the steelers
when they won
uh tom when he won
it's hard to keep track you you
mentioned the steelers so was that
steelers cardinals yes those are one of
few and i know you were broadcasting
during the chuck knoll terry bradshaw
europe but i don't know if you were
doing super bowls yet um
i would argue the one thing i would
disagree with tom on well there are
maybe a few but one of the things is
the malcolm butler play was great but
the greatest defensive play forget
football history in super bowl history
is james harrison's it literally can't
get better and more impactful than the
99 yards at halftime to take one
touchdown away and score a touchdown for
your team no there's a second half to go
in that game
yeah but it was it was a 14 point swing
it was a 14 point so you can't get more
impactful than that yes because butler
he saved the game
the game is over if they score
right but but if the but if butler just
knocks it down
the patriots still have a very good
chance of winning it was not more
impactful james harrison play was better
i can't even arguing about this tom
brady's not here right now you can tell
the truth you don't have to just agree
malcolm butler's play is the greatest in
super bowl history because in the moment
it won the super bowl james harrison in
the moment didn't win the super bowl
they went into halftime with a whole lot
of momentum
malcolm butler doesn't make the play
seattle gets maybe two more chances to
win the super bowl and then there's no
time left for tom brady
all right so then you're so according to
that logic because it was the final
thing not the ultimate thing the final
thing you're with me you and me the only
two people in america that believe
2016 nba finals game seven the biggest
shot was not kyrie's to go up three but
lebron's free throw with the obviously
fractured wrist to go up four that won
them the game it was later it happened
it was two possessions same logic the
other no clearly kyrie's shot was bigger
harrison's thing was more impressive and
important it's a 14 point swing they
would have lost there was 23 seconds
left in the super bowl
what are you talking about
you've never been more wrong and you're
wrong a lot and okay well then hold on
hold on a second so is every
get is every touchdown so the super the
touchdown that the patriots scored to
beat the falcons right to end the game
in overtime yeah was that a bigger play
than the wes welker catch or was it
edelman i don't know who it was
guys
edelman edelman's was edelman's was
bigger right
yeah you were in overtime with the
touchdown
yeah
okay all right listen you don't lose the
game if they don't get in they don't
lose the game
and if if the if malcolm butler doesn't
pick that ball off the patriots still
could win
it's not like well he wasn't walking in
for the game-winning touchdown and he
jars the ball loose if he the the
patriots still wouldn't be uh able to
win if butler just knocks it in the odds
are very very very very small i don't
know he listened to tommy tommy he was
saying you couldn't run the football i
didn't hear much pushback on that either
be like tom come on you can run the
football and the defense wasn't that
great give me a break but doesn't matter
that's what they were geared up for the
run they were geared up for the run
that's all yeah i get i understand that
but i've also heard wise men tell me
football is about two grown men and one
imposing their will on the other then
larry allen didn't he tell you that they
used to occasionally when they were
running to him he would make a choo choo
noise like train coming this way let
everybody know not stopping us anyway
it's marshawn lynch man all right sorry
i've derailed you
you want to try this again
i mean we can i mean i'm still a little
mad at you for reasons we don't have to
discuss we can keep that between us
um but yeah we can try it again i don't
i'm not gonna admit i'm not gonna
guarantee you i'm gonna be less ornery
okay
i had 10 minutes with brady
okay
i had to do
two mentions of the hertz
commercials that he said you fit that in
well i like it so i had to do that and i
know that what you're saying and you're
going to be upset about is you didn't
hammer him over the miami dolphins
right
okay well further okay just for the
record that is not what i was saying i
was upset about i was upset about
something far more personal that like i
said we will keep off the air
relating to our wonderful dinner date oh
your wife however you're one okay all
right well i guess it's not off the air
yeah i mean that's fine but we can get
to the brady stuff too whatever you like
yes i'm mad at you about i'm mad at you
about the interaction with my wife i'm
disappointed in you
about not hammering brady about the
dolphin you wanted me just to be on the
record to say tom
what happened with the dolphin so i
would have just been on record and he
would have deflected and i didn't have
enough time if i had 20 minutes with him
15 minutes if i had full time and not a
sponsor to work in
then it's something that you can broach
the topic i would have done a one-off
with him
and i wouldn't have gotten anything with
him
even though i am i am damn patrick i
didn't have you handed him the keys to
the truck i did he has respect for you i
did you're not somebody from the sun
sentinel where he's gonna give you know
just pablum to he might say you know
what dan i've been waiting for a
journalist
of your caliber to ask me this question
i do agree
that you've said this before
and mike florio has pointed this out
florio's been hammering this since
february and he's been right with it but
because shefty didn't report it
it feels like it kind of floated away
and do i think it's real yes
sean payton that he was going to be the
coach what was going to happen to tua
what would be uh trade compensation for
the saints with sean payton what would
be trade compensation with brady uh
there's a lot that goes into it
absolutely do i think brady wanted to
play for the dolphins because he wanted
to be part owner yes i do absolutely he
was derailed by brian flores the uh
lawsuit there
no and i am i and i'm giving you a hard
time i mean you got but you got the you
did a great job with tom obviously and
you did have limited time and he
filibustered on the three players thing
he gives 15 guys i mean come on tom show
some discipline like maybe you'd have
eight rings not seven a little more
discipline like answer the question uh
but yeah i mean i just it is
tom brady is the
biggest star in the nfl one could argue
the biggest star in american sports the
only other star in american sports of
his caliber is active is lebron
and if lebron fake retired from the
lakers
to spend time with brawny and savannah
and then six weeks later came back and
then we found out it was because he was
trying to join the mavericks
like i feel like it would lead some
shows for a few years as opposed to just
like no matter i don't care who reported
it um but yeah i mean i agree
i agree i've been disappointed in how
the networks and you know we i'm on a
network so we we could have we could
have talked about it more uh have not
made this like wow that is a wild story
but i i do think it's cool that you have
two you know all-time great fox
employees on the show as your only two
guests today also a buddy of mine text
tweeted out the picture my buddy laszlo
who's the biggest tom brady fan in the
world tweeted out the picture that you
guys put out there and said why does tom
look younger than nick he's like god
dawg
he's eight years older than me and he's
like good point but it's like a good
point keep this in mind tom brady was
the warm-up to you
that's how i felt like i was like you
know what this is a great lean in like
people are like oh here's tom and now
wait wait till nick wright comes on
i'm going to talk to nick about the
question i should be asking tom about
see if tom will come back on and he can
critique this interview todd he can be
like you should have asked nick here's
what he should add you should ask nick
about the time he said i was washed four
super bowls
why doesn't nick criticize skip
bayless's take
what are you talking about what do you
mean no tom might say that
once i see a bad one i will
wow
wow
wow
you just lost all credibility there what
do you mean what are you talking about
uh so every take he has on lebron is a
great technique well listen i don't
listen i have so much media to do i do
my own job blah blah blah
i can't consume everything
across all i'm just saying the ones that
come across my desk i'm like you know
what seems pretty reasonable to me he's
nick wright uh first things first
co-host fox sports one um
it was great meeting your wife when we
went to dinner and she came in at the
very end of the dinner she was it was
very nice
it was she's a wonderful woman she is a
business owner i didn't know what i did
that was wrong
i mean i don't i i'm not
okay you i mean you've opened this door
so now i just assume we can walk through
it okay i mean i think at some point you
implied
that you could buy her a fine piece of
jewelry if she'd if she'd hang out a
little bit longer okay i can't get one
point yeah go ahead
okay can i guess we've opened up the
door
yeah
and you wear a fake breitling on first
things first
okay
you you you
you're the son of a man you said you
bought three fake breitlings
great and one real one for her for her
hers is real
mine that i only wear on television is
what we call
a high quality and fake
effect high quality
so you are confirming the story
well i'm not gonna lie to the audience i
didn't expect wow you really
like i thought i knew where you were
going to go with this
but no instead you went straight to
pocket shaming you basically called me a
broke boy
i just said look if your wife needed a
breitling
yeah come to daddy
[Laughter]
wow
are we on the air no we're not no
no we're not what's happening you opened
the door
i didn't mean to open the door i said i
was mad at you for something that would
stay off the air you then assumed i was
mad at your shoddy journalist instead
i was mad at your
lack of decorum
and then now we're now we're there this
is at this point you know what at this
point forget of breitling because of
these last four minutes i think at the
very least you've got to get her a cameo
or an extra
thing in the next sandler flick i think
she'd look good on the silver screen i
think that could work i you know what as
photogenic as your wife is i think that
i could uh i could do that
i think you could i did i did hug
nick's wife
but for a long time
it was elongated hug i think i called
her gorgeous too hey gorgeous when she
came up to the table i just thought it
was a fan
i
i thought because she didn't acknowledge
you and she acknowledged me she went
high she was excited she was excited to
meet you she's only here that's true
she's only human
okay
before i let you go
uh-huh when did you come to the
realization that you were going to
change your finals pick from the golden
state warriors to the boston celtics
when i'll tell you the exact moment in
fact i can timestamp tell you
because i i know when i did it which was
it was 8 33 am
the day after
the warriors won game two so that next
day the warriors have just won that game
in a blowout
the next day
we are on the air
and i bet
on the celtics to win the title i was
like we'd been talking about it for an
hour and i was like and so the moment i
did that
i'm like okay
i now just have to i'm not gonna again
as proven by this entire interview i am
nothing if not honest i'm not gonna
literally bet on one team and then come
on television and act like i don't think
they're going to win now i have put
myself in the position to potentially be
wrong multiple times here and that's
less than ideal and my freezing cold
andrew wiggins take was being sent to me
and honest to god in hebrew
it's gone international i am getting
attacked from multiple continents for
one bad take um so none of it's great
but that's when it happened i was like
if i'm going to bet the celtics i should
probably just say on tv i think the
celtics are going to win
got a text from the west bank here and
uh you know yeah it wasn't great man
whenever someone has a screenshot of an
old take of you yeah and their tweet it
says beneath it translate tweet question
mark you're like oh christ this is not
great but if the celtics come back you
know it's a nice victory lap
kind of but then see what people will
still be like oh you picked the warriors
to begin with listen man i'm i'm these
these nba playoffs i was riding you know
every once in a while it's good to get
humbled whether it's by
you know
one of your radio and television mentors
hitting on your wife in front of you or
whether it's by the sports world it's
celebrating your demise i
i was riding maybe a little too high
after the mavs beat the suns i maybe
took a bit too much of a victory lap
calling everyone else in the media dumb
saying i saw things they didn't see
you know questioning people's integrity
and basketball iq and since that moment
i think i've gotten every single series
wrong
so i want to uh ask my audience uh to
make sure that they watch
nick wright on
first
fox sports first things he's got jokes
the pinky ring's real though and more
importantly the diamond chains i can't
wear them first things first you saw
them in person
nothing fake about those lines no listen
we we have limited with limited uh
jewelry budgets in this household my
wife in the chains take up the lion's
share of it so we got to go imposter
watch tell your wife i said hello
i won't be doing that
thank you nick
we're back after this